[Music]
this episode is sponsored by grammarly
stick around for an attractive offer
only for our viewers
the sun isn't the biggest thing in our
solar system
and it's not jupiter either
but close it's jupiter's very own
magnetic field
what would it be like if earth's
magnetic field was as huge as jupiter's
how much stronger would our
magnetosphere become
why would it make solar radiation worse
this is what if and here's what would
happen if earth had jupiter's magnetic
field
earth is surrounded by electrically
charged particles affected by our
planet's magnetic field
this is called the magnetosphere and it
plays an invisible but very important
role in keeping our planet livable
without it we'd be left unprotected from
the sun's radiation
plus our atmosphere would leak out into
the great beyond
so give a big thanks to our
magnetosphere that extends as far as 65
000 kilometers into space
our magnetic field is generated by a
dynamo effect inside the earth's core
that's when liquid metals in the outer
core create electric currents and then
the earth's rotation on its axis causes
these currents to act like a magnet
if this magnetic field is so great for
us
let's turn up the dial and make it
thousands of times stronger
the fingers crossed it won't attract
meteorites that would level your city in
minutes
but the most attractive deal right now
is what's going on at grammarly you know
every word matters in storytelling
especially when unraveling the mysteries
of the universe and with grammarly as my
go-to writing tool well i know
everything i present comes across as
clear concise and professional right
well that's why i use grammarly for
every script and with their free tone
detector i know i'm hitting the right
notes for the right audience you but
you've got to see it for yourself
download grammarly for free on your
desktop or mobile device yeah you heard
that right go to grammarly.com
what if to sign up for a free account
and when you're ready to upgrade to
grammarly premium well you get 20 off
for being our viewer that's twenty
percent off at g r a m m a r l y dot com
slash what if
you know grammarly can help you attract
the audience you want but
i'm not sure they can do much about
meteors
if you could see jupiter's magnetic
field from earth
it would appear nearly three times the
size of our moon
and that's huge considering that jupiter
is a whopping
778 million kilometers away from us
when you got close to this behemoth of
the solar system you'd see it extending
three million kilometers from jupiter
toward the sun
and over 1 billion kilometers in the
other direction
all the way to saturn
if earth suddenly had a magnetic field
this huge it would easily swallow up the
moon
and it would extend out past mars the
main asteroid belt and into jupiter's
orbit
but there's a catch
the size of a planet's magnetic field
depends on how strong that field is and
the strength of the solar winds it comes
in contact with
these solar winds are the reason that
the site of jupiter's magnetic field
facing the sun is more compressed
while the other extends much further
like earth jupiter's magnetic field is
generated in its core by liquid metals
enormous amounts of pressure turned
liquid hydrogen into a metallic form
only jupiter's core is much larger
significantly hotter and rotates even
faster
so for earth to have a stronger magnetic
field our core would have to speed up
and get hotter
much hotter
and if we somehow made our planetary
core rotate faster than jupiter's
our magnetic field would become 18 000
times more powerful than it is today
but does stronger always equal better
one of the bigger issues you'd have to
confront with this new bigger stronger
magnetosphere
is that it would no longer be so good at
protecting the planet from dangerous
charged particles from the sun
that's because it would now behave a lot
like a particle accelerator
this would be extra concerning if you
had space travel planned anytime soon
all because the trapped solar particles
bombard satellites the iss and the moon
with large amounts of radiation
and nothing would stop them from passing
through the ship's exterior
this would damage all your electronics
unless they were stored inside a one and
a half centimeter thick titanium vault
and if you were unlucky enough to be
bombarded by these charged particles on
a spacewalk
you could get radiation sickness and
increase your chances of getting cancer
this could also [ __ ] your nervous
system so you definitely don't want to
find yourself floating in space
surrounded by a magnetic field with that
much kick
down on earth the aurora borealis or
northern lights would get an upgraded
look
these form when the electrically charged
particles collide with oxygen and
nitrogen atoms
now you would see the display pulsing
oh and they'd be dangerous too
that's because they'd be emitting x-rays
and that radiation could get funneled
right down to the ground
this could lead to our poles becoming
completely uninhabitable
now how about giving earth a magnetic
field from a planet thirteen hundred
times its size impact you directly
well try living with a core moving so
fast you'd be dealing with a dramatic
increase in earthquake and volcanic
activity
and let's not forget animals like bees
sharks and even mud snails that rely on
earth's magnetosphere to keep them
pointed in the right direction
they'd all be thrown off course with
potentially disastrous effects on global
ecosystems
now what would happen if earth's
magnetic field got so small that it
completely disappeared
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]